what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday october the 18th from the
heart of [__] jersey the joint
is brought to you by
draftkings nfl fans are you hungry for a
big [__] win
tonight's tonight monday night
[__] football you understand me
draftking sportsbook has you covered
new customers can bet
five dollars did you hear what i'm
saying
five dollars on any nfl team
to win their game and if they do
you win
in free bets
who is better than [__] you nobody
winner winner
chicken [__] dinner you
understand me that's how we're doing it
on a [__] uh
on a [__] monday tonight you
got the buffalo bills minus five and a
half
against the tennessee titans and you got
an over and under a 50 [__] three
that's a game and a half that's one for
you to [__] start with and if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
yet
or you don't want to bet nfl football i
got an idea for you draftkings will not
leave you with your dick in your hand
everybody can play draftkings daily
fantasy sports contest
you get huge cash prizes all seasons
long draftkings is giving away
new customers a free shot ready for this
at the fantasy side a million [__]
dollars come on guys i know you're gonna
do some fantasy draftkings is the way to
go and i'm gonna tell you something else
about draftkings they have their own
social network
so after you join draftkings
i'm on the [__] network we could go
back and forth on there i'll give you a
little pics i'm getting from the philly
godfather or whatever i'm there to work
with you download the draftking
sportsbook app today right now it's
monday [__] thursday we got action we
got baseball all week and basketball
is around the [__] corner
all right so download the draftking
sports book app today use promo code
joey bet 5 hours on any nfl team to win
that game
and draftkings is going to give you
200 and free bets you understand me you
can't beat that like i said we're going
into the season you got college football
you got basketball you got the world
series are you [__] crazy use promo
code joey this week at
draftkingsportsbook
the official sports betting part of the
nfl now here's the stuff the lawyers
make me say you guys know what the deal
is you got to be 21 or older get the
[__] kazoo
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only all
the other states
that allow gambling colorado tennessee
new customers only minimum five dollar
deposit
with a five dollar wager required one
per customer
one per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings dot com slash sport book for
details if you got a gambling problem
call 1-800
gamble but if not head over to
draftkings join the social network [__]
around with uncle joey but most
importantly win some [__] guitars
with code joey
the church i mean the joint is also
brought to you by my [__] favorite to
the end of time c
b
d
lion
why do i love cbd lion as much because
they turned me on to a world of [__]
just feeling better
whether it's the tablets the caps
whether it's the smoke whether it's the
joints the loose
cbd weed
the special extra special cream the
kinesiology tape the back balls
cbd has it all
the gummies are to die for to die for
with melatonin
you sleep like a [__] baby i've been
telling you guys for the last month that
my sleeping has gone up
to [__] uh
8.1 hours of [__] month
i credit cbd line with the cbn
the cby the whole [__] package so do
me a favor go to cbdline.com
download not download read what's on the
page
and learn about cbd you're going to be
[__] happy from anxiety to knee pain
to shoulder pain you put a piece of tape
on you you put a piece of kinesiology
tape i'll tell you guys it works
miracles but you know what
take it don't take it from me go to cbd
line read all about cbd cbn cby get back
to me if i was you i'd start off with
the gummies
go to cbd lion make an order and press
in joey or joint
or church and get 20 off delivered right
to your [__] house you can't beat
that how long are you going to wait to
give this a shot today is the day
go to cbdline.com right now
press and join joey and get 20 off any
of the tremendous products delivered to
that to your house all right
i love you [__] let's get this
[__] party started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 18th we're here for
another fun-filled episode of uncle
joey's joint i hope you all had a great
weekend everything worked out for you i
had a great weekend you know same [__]
nothing changes the week was a little
[__] weird
uh some things happened socially in our
lives that we need to discuss today
because
it's getting too [__] uh it's getting
too [__] woke out there and the [__]
that happened this week
really
as you guys know i do not like when
people bring up [__]
from 20 years ago that's just wrong
because people change
let's just talk about life right now
in the last year how much have i changed
right before your eyes
how much have i changed people change
constantly their thoughts
their opinions on things you know when i
was a kid i hated cats i just [__]
hated cats i see a cat i throw a rock at
it now i got [__] cats i love [__]
cats you know
but uh if it ain't one thing it's the
other in our society nowadays but we're
just getting too [__] woke
i noticed it when i left los angeles
that
there had been a just a a a [__]
change you know for starters let's talk
about john gruden you know listen i i'm
not a raider fan
i'm not a fan of anybody i'm a fan of
[__] life okay
they were doing an investigation
into the washington redskins they went
through emails supposedly this is what i
read
and heard and
they [__] found the emails of him
going back and forth one of the coaches
the general managers i don't know
exactly what it is i don't want to say
it before i get myself in trouble
and they found these emails with him
talking about uh
you know roger goodell and [__] uh
talking about some player in the league
that had big lips or something like that
listen it's wrong
i get it
i get what we're trying to do here
but i don't think firing him
was really a [__] you know and i don't
know what's happened to people
that they've lost their balls you know
like
you know al davis's son
is the [__] he you know he's the
president i guess i don't know exactly
what happened
i know he got fired i know it was
against the nfl policies and stuff like
that but
when he sent the emails he wasn't even
working
for the nfl now
let's take a look at his situation he's
an nfl coach
now
i don't know
what do you think at home 60 percent of
the nfl is african-american
he's been a [__] coach with the
raiders
tampa bay
and then went back to the raiders
if he was racist in any way
don't you think one of the players would
have said it after all these years
i've seen him on there hugging
african-american players and joking
around with them and you know i've been
watching him for [__] i don't know 20
[__] years i don't know
then he coached tampa bay early on you
know i watched him then i used to i met
him on the world uh the best damn sports
show
when he was uh coaching tampa bay and uh
he seemed like an all-right guy i mean i
don't know i don't know what people do
behind closed doors
and i understand it was behind closed
doors and it was a joke i've made
many off-color jokes
many off-color jokes over the year but i
have a past
so just when when that first started
with the [__] uh
the supreme court justice that dude that
put it cover the girl's mouth 20 years
ago at a party but didn't do nothing to
her where is she today
what did she get out of raising her hand
20 years [__] later
and what do you get from raising your
hand 20 years later from my behavior
then
obviously you don't think i corrected it
over the years obviously you don't think
that even me for example the other day i
was at my friend's house to pumas and i
was walking back
and there's a [__] amazon guy
and he's an african-american kid and
he's got the [__] volume blasted in
the rap car in the car and he's playing
that [__] rap music the real slow one
i don't i don't know i like old school
rap nahs and all that stuff this is
something new
and the guy keeps saying you know the
n-word over and over and it's loud in my
neighborhood you know it's [__] loud
i remember walking and going you know
what
nothing bothers me more than that [__]
nothing bothers me more that [__] and
you guys know i love cracking jokes and
nobody is sacred the french
african-americans chinese you know i was
thinking about when mike came in today i
go you know what it's getting cold out
there the temperature dropped to like 62
to open up you know it just dropped a
couple you know last week the last three
weeks it's been opening up at 70. all of
a sudden today it went down to 60
[__] dude is it cold out no but you
could feel the chill in here i said to
mike
just you know i didn't even think about
it guys
[__] there's nip in the air you know and
right away you're like wow i can't even
[__] say that no more i didn't mean
it in a bad way there's nip in here nip
is a
uh
uh you know a racial slur if you want to
use it like that so no pun intended i
mean it's getting a little nippy in the
air that's it
but even saying something like that
somebody might look at you and go joey
you're wrong for saying that
okay you know i won't say it if it means
not saying it i won't say it to
to make you [__] happy but there's
another side to this coin so we'll get
to that in a second here
but i've never liked that that you could
go to somebody after 12 years i think
there would be a better way to handle
this i think i think charles gruden i
think rudin
i think i would have made him do an
apology
i think i would have had him uh
take classes for awareness or something
two classes talk to somebody i don't
know if you guys remember
about ten years ago
ralphie may went off on some indians
i don't know if you guys remember that
you know ralphie always went off on
everybody the russians the indians he
went off on american indians if you knew
anything about ralphie
he was a sweetheart
and i gotta be honest it was a [__]
joke
it was a joke
you know
some chief of the tribe took it
seriously they canceled this gig did
they cancel them no you know what the
chief wanted to do
educate them
so they set up a meeting with ralphie
they spoke to him
they explained to him where they were
coming from
and everybody moved on
he made a little contribution
nobody got their [__] feelings hurt
you know when you do something like this
i'd rather you get
whoever the group is and explain to us
how these things are hurtful i don't
know if you guys know about this but i'm
telling you i hope he doesn't get mad at
me
years ago tom segura said something on
one of his specials
you know they didn't pull a special down
what they did was
they set up a meeting between the
president of the
special olympics
and tom
to educate him on
how the word
[__] affects
people when you say it
now what you do with that is your choice
you know when you go home you go you
know what i choose not to say [__]
anymore or i'm gonna keep saying [__]
[__]
that's it that that's it educate me on
why
it's wrong and we can move forward
and then it's my decision whether to say
it again
or not to say it again
you know
whenever this type of [__] happens it
makes the net my neck can't stand up it
really [__] does
because i've had a pass but i know where
i am today
and you know what don't say that oh well
joey that's you no
i know a lot of people who've changed
like i've seen it now
i've been gone for 30 [__] years i've
been gone since 1990 [__] three i
come back here
and i see friends of mine and i ask
about them or whatever and they've
changed
they've turned their lives around
whatever they used to do they don't do
no more you have to evolve as a human
being that is very important i try to
evolve as much as i [__] can you know
sometimes i can't but you try you try to
[__] change you look at yourself and
go i could be this much better today you
know for me it was the drugs
i had to get off the [__] cocaine and
every and i knew it made me a better
person and then after i got cleaned and
my mind got right
because when you're on drugs your mind
is not
[__] right
so after i got off the drugs i thought
about all the things i had done over the
years
and i [__]
you know
changed them around to the best of my
ability
that's all you could do and you have to
be very honest with yourself to do
something like that to actually sit down
and go dawg i've been [__] up
with this [__] lately i have to reinvent
myself
you know i have to [__] reinvent
myself that's what it's all about
so for the charles gruden thing that
charles gruden uh gruden
whatever his name is john gruden or
whatever the [__] his name is you know
they took his [__] so because he said
something 13 years ago or nine years or
whatever the [__] 2012 i think it was
we're gonna take him down off the ring
we're gonna take him off a [__] uh
sports game we're gonna just [__]
chastise him
who the [__] are we to do that as
americans
that's what this is this is america
the land of [__] opportunity and now
we're taking food out of people's mouths
yeah gruden will be back in a year a
year and a half on some sports network
as an analyst but that's a year and a
half that he has to stay in this house
with the [__] shades drawn
because
somebody wasn't happy with what he said
12 [__] years ago i don't i don't
agree with that guys and my heart goes
out to the african-american community
and my heart goes out to the gay
community for the whatever he said but
at this at the same time it was a joke
have we forgotten what a [__] joke is
have we forgotten i mean have we just
forgotten that somebody's saying a joke
now the other thing that happened that
was [__] uh
bad was the dave chappelle thing now you
guys know where i stand with this
and as far as all that [__] goes
you've got the wrong [__] you
really do have the wrong [__]
i i can't tell you in so many ways how
you got the wrong [__] now
before we get this [__]
curtain of this started
i'm a stand-up
i read the book lenny bruce ladies and
gentlemen lenny bruce and that's what
led me to that career yes i had been
into richard pryor over the years and
yes i was a fan of stand-up you know i
was a fan of uh the white dude the crazy
i was a phantom whatever
you know i read a book and i decided to
get into stand-up comedy when i started
stand-up comedy i was giving advice
you're giving a lot of advice and people
tell you
not to do this not to say this to be
clean you know sinbad spoke to me when i
started all these guys joey you're
talented you don't have to be dirty no
you have to be whatever your heart calls
for
so let's get this straight when i first
got on that stage i went out there to be
the best entertainer i could be
i did not want to use curse words and
stuff i went out there with a suit on
i comb my hair i you know i did i did as
much as i could to be a regular
entertainer at that time it was lenny
clark i saw lenny clark with a suit on
do the rodney special and i lost my
[__] mind i knew i had to be
part of that so
okay
i tried stand-up comedy for like nine
months in the beginning
and i bombed being clean and i went to
my go-to
i went to me being dirty that and all my
life since i heard richard pryor i was
dirty i loved speaking that [__] i loved
it
i got into stand-up comedy now before i
got into stand-up comedy i read a lot
about it
i read as much as i could biographies i
watch videos i ask questions
now the anatomy of this
stand up is
how your world
your world
collides
with the rest of the [__] world
how your world collides
with the rest of the world that's the
that's the the smallest equation for
comedy if you come to me and you pay me
and you go joey i need you to coach me
tell me what's the meaning of comedy
it's how my world collides with the rest
of the world
okay
i'll give you an example i have a child
when i was a kid i [__] suffered a
lot with my allergies i was allergic to
dogs
and i was allergic to maple [__]
syrup okay
in my house you know i had dogs my
mother had a dog at the dry cleaner when
i was a kid
the people next door to me had [__]
dogs i it felt like i was surrounded by
dogs all the time i got bit by dogs
[__] eight or nine times i got bit in
the face i got bit in the leg i got bit
in the hand
it doesn't [__] matter here i liked
dogs
i would pet a dog and my eyes would
swell and my nose would leak and my
throats my throat was shut and i would
end up in the [__] hospital
uh
[__] maple syrup you know how can you
tell a [__] kid
he's allergic to [__] maple syrup
when i came from cuba my mother used to
make you know
rice with eggs on top
[__] steak with eggs on top pure
[__] disgusting [__]
it's good but it's [__] disgusting
you know the egg the steak with the egg
on top we're walking ohio with the white
rice and you break the [__] yolk over
the steak and it drips onto the meat and
the rice
i don't know
it just it just doesn't work for me guys
so
all of a sudden i went to like school or
something somebody turned me onto a
[__] pancake
i put the [__] syrup on it like in
the first grade and next thing you know
i'm dizzy i'm passed out and i'm in a
[__] ambulance going to some hospital
and my mother's meet me up this is a
true [__] story guys
and then they told us we were allergic
to maple syrup the sweetness and then
something happened with honey when i was
a kid and i got [__] taken to the
hospital again i was a mess when i was a
kid i was allergic to all that [__]
okay it was [__] horrible
you know what it is to [__] i i still
remember being in my first summer camp
like you know where you go and do
push-ups and jump off a diving board and
all that [__] i still remember going and
them giving us pancakes for breakfast
and me like you know what do you think
there was an alternative [__] menu in
those days what do you think like you
could call ahead and say i want a vegan
menu [__] you
there's hot dogs and [__] it was hot
dogs for lunch and pancakes for
breakfast
that's it there was no scrambled eggs
there was no toast there was [__]
nothing so i had to go there in the
mornings and i'd eat the [__] uh you
know i love syrup i love the [__]
taste of maple syrup who the [__]
doesn't
but between two minutes my eyes would
get red i'd start blinking my throat
would shut it was a [__] nightmare
so we decided my mom and i sat down one
day like when i was six and we decided
joey listen
my mother was old-school cuban she told
me to [__] just go and play with the
[__] dogs but after i play with the
dogs i keep washing my hands
wash your hands wash your hands and
after you wash your hands well wash your
face so it doesn't and you know what
guys
it worked
it worked i was telling my neighbors
they have a dog named molly a
short-haired pit and i go these are the
dogs that would this little hair would
get into my [__] nose and i'd go off
the boundary you know they couldn't even
believe it they're like and you're
allergic to dogs the other day i went
over there i was sitting on that porch
she was sitting on my legs and i'm
[__] patting that she's a great dog
i'm petting her and frank looks at me
and he goes you're really allergic to
dogs i go listen we worked on it
we just we played with so many dogs that
we broke the allergy today
today 2021
i eat pancakes three times a year
not [__] two stacks not three stacks
one with a little bit of syrup a little
bit of butter
i eat it
and nothing happens that's the most i
can handle
is three maybe four times it's a little
breakfast place
called [__] stacks
close to my house
holy [__] they make nutella pancakes
they make [__] uh
banana pancakes with little bananas on
top and it tastes like banana cream pie
i mean i'm not into that sweet [__] but
i've tasted them [__] delicious my
point being
that i overcame that [__]
my allergies my mom
forced me
to overcome these allergies
circle back to 2010
2011 2012 who the [__] knows i don't
[__] know
um you know uh no 2013 i put my daughter
in school and my daughter's born and a
year later with you know three months
later we're in daycare whatever whatever
the [__] it was we try to to get her
social skills so it had to be like 2015.
i find out one day that i can't bring
peanut butter
she can't pack peanut butter to the
[__] school
i nearly lost my mind my mind almost
[__] blew the [__] up
because i'm like what are you talking
about now like yeah because if other
kids are allergic to peanuts so what
does that have to do with my [__] kid
if my kid's not allergic to peanuts
what's it have to do with that so
i [__]
never thought about it again then one
day i was taking a flight from like la
to san diego and [__] uh there were
no peanuts i'm stoned to the gills i'm
looking forward to these [__] peanuts
and that's the day southwest don't put
out the [__] peanuts now am i a
peanut dude
you know i like peanuts i like peanuts
and a snickers bar
i like a couple things with peanuts
but i get on the [__] plane that day
and i'm looking forward to these peanuts
and these goddamn pretzels for some
reason i'm looking forward to the
[__] peanuts and boom there's no
peanuts i asked the lady i go what's
going on with the peanuts here i'm
sitting here like [__] patience on a
monument she says to me there's no
peanuts today we have one passenger
that's allergic to peanuts
i was blown the [__] away guys i was
like what the [__] are you talking about
so because one motherfucker's allergic
to peanuts i can't eat my [__]
peanuts
what the [__] is the world coming to so
right away i went home what stand-up
comedy how your world collides with the
rest of the [__] world so right away
i went home and i had to write a [__]
bit on this i went online i read about
this [__] penalty and i was blown the
[__] away
and i read a bit i wrote a bit on a
[__] simple thing a penalty now the
kid give him a [__] peanut he ain't
gonna die
he's gonna go to the hospital you know
he'll probably swell up blah blah blah
let me tell you something i have said
some disgusting things on stage i have
mugged hookers on stage i have [__]
uh crawled in windows and eating [__]
on i've said some disgusting things on
stage
never have i gotten off stage and
somebody said to me hey man
we didn't like that joke it was
inappropriate i talked about a chick
pissing on me 20 years i talked about
tons of [__] nobody ever pulled me aside
and said joey this is inappropriate do
you know how many times
i got pulled aside for that [__]
peanut joke
every [__] show when i would take
pictures of people
some some sort of parents would come up
to me and go hey man
we you were funny we really enjoy you we
like the podcast we like what you're
doing we like what you stand for
but the peanut joke was offensive as
[__] we have a child that has a penalty
and he could die i don't know if you
understand the whatevers of this and i
would get turnt off and in my mind tell
them to go [__] themselves like just
give them that look like take a [__]
hike with your little [__] [__]
peanut kid you know what's it got to do
with me you're going to come beat me up
on a [__] saturday night or a [__]
joke
so but
eventually you know i i kept taking my
daughter to school i kept hearing from
[__] people whatever
it was just a joke i i get it
but that stupid [__] joke right there
caused me so much [__] heartache how
many people would come at me after the
[__] show i would get emails about it
i would get facebook messes about it you
know what it was a simple [__] joke
you know i stopped saying it i shot a
special i put on a cd whatever who the
[__] knows what happened but the bottom
line is it was just a [__]
joke you know and i really learned from
that joke
on how people
could
get hurt
now
with the same [__] thing from me
discovering all these things because i
listen when you don't have a kid you
don't know anything about these things
like and i'm sure you know you guys are
young listening you're like joey i know
about peanut allergies i know because
you had it but when i was growing up
there was no [__] peanut allergies no
kids had a [__] peniology so trust me
this is something that's taken me by
[__] storm the same thing again a tip
a bad subject to bring up but we're
gonna bring it up who gives a [__]
transsexuals transvestites whatever the
[__]
listen
i don't they don't bother me at all i
could care less i i've had three dear
friends
in my life that have been transgenders
or had the operation
and we had fun we laughed about it it
was phenomenal i had one up you know
rita oh me and josh wolf have spoken
about it repeatedly she used to carry
her old dick in a jar you know
this chick had the sexual yeah yeah it
was
guys you have no idea how
we had tons of conversations now
years ago it started with
i found out at colfax elementary in la
where we started talking about
switching governments where we started
talking about you know
uh
gender reveal parties and all this stuff
listen
i'm from the 70s
you know i can't wrap my head around
this stuff
about
a little boy one day waking up and
coming to me and saying
i think i'm a girl this is tough guys
this is tough
to wrap your arms around you know
especially as a parent do i think that
one day
my daughter's gonna come to me and go
you know what dad cut the [__] out i'm
slinging dick like you i want to be a
[__] boy i would
i would be in shock i wouldn't really
know how to handle it i would have to do
a lot of reading on it i would have to
do a lot but i've never heard of this
before i have never heard this is
something that you know i'm 58 [__]
years old and i started hearing about
this
when i was 50 and now they're gonna put
it into the school systems and whatnot
and as a parent you're sitting there
going do i want my child exposed to this
anyway to make a long [__] story
short
this week
the dave chappelle the special came out
closer
you know i didn't even know he had shot
another special i didn't know it was his
last special on uh netflix i knew
nothing about it before we get into this
conversation do me a favor
now for a word from our sponsor we'll be
back in 60 minutes
the joint is also brought to you by
better help online therapy
going to therapy is routine maintenance
for your mental and emotional wellness
to prevent bigger issues down the road i
didn't know this until i started working
with betterhelp.com listen dana is my
girl she's talked me through this thing
for the last month and i feel that much
better i went to them
and asked them if they needed
if they were working with sponsors and
podcasts because i wanted you guys to
know
how much it helped me going to therapy
doesn't mean there's something wrong
with you guys it means you're investing
in yourself to keep your mind healthy
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can start communicating
with your therapist in under 48 hours
why invest in anything else
and not your mind
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and joint listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
joey that's betterhelp.com
joey and now let's go back to the
podcast
listen
i love uh
i love uh what do you call that [__]
better help so if you're having a little
problem if you've got a little hang on
the nail
on the fence i hang on the fence or
whatever i suggest you go to
betterhelp.com but anyway back to what
we were [__] talking about here this
week the dave chappelle special got
released i didn't know he had another
special
you know like i said guys i'm i've been
my head's been somewhere else
i turn on the computer one morning and
all i'm reading is about dave chappelle
how he insulted people the second day
i [__] opened up the computer and
it's all over the place
dave chappelle's getting canceled
he got a standing ovation at the
hollywood bowl
so i said [__] it i'm a stand-up i'm a
human being let me watch this special
to see what i think about and see what
all the fuss is about okay
here you
go it was a very good special
dave did a very good job
i liked the stories i liked how he
presented the material
he told some lgbt btq stories on there
about a
friend of his that died and
the baby and all this stuff
guys listen this is where i'm coming
from with this uh i know some people are
not gonna sit right with this and i know
some people are gonna agree with with me
we're gonna attack this from two
perspectives okay
number one perspective
dave is a comic
what's his job
to be funny
what's his job well some comics jobs
some
not mine
are to
kill
society not kill society
but explain to you in a funny way the
wrongs of society what's going on in the
world today with a funny twist to it
what's happening and again
the main thing a comic's supposed to be
doing up there
is explain to you how his world collides
with the world you live it
so if you take all that into
consideration
dave hit it out of the park he did a
phenomenal job okay that's what a
stand-up comic
is supposed to do
there's a downside to this
dave
is at the top of the world right now
okay when you're in the top of the world
you're a lightning rod it's like being a
mafia boss
everybody's coming to you that's why for
the last
20 years you have a boss and a street
boss
because
the street boss is getting hidden
by the boss of the family the feds
everybody's concerned
with the boss of the family in this case
it's society
everybody's concerned
with what the top comic has to say
he is the top comic
in the country by enough by a [__]
mile okay
nobody could even touch him
he's saying
what affects him which is the lgbtq
stuff whatever but
dave is also being cute right now
so
dave
davis comedy aptitude is off the [__]
chain
my comedy aptitude is not that great
that was why i was never a great comic i
was a funny comic i knew what i was
doing i could bang it out with anybody
but my comedy aptitude as far as being
well read as dave or joe rogan for that
matter or bill burr
i'm more of a life comic like i like
talking about what's
in my life what affects me
you know there's people that'll take a
subject out of the newspaper and write a
brilliant bit about it but it doesn't
affect them i spoke i speak about things
about my life i'm more of a storyteller
and that's just me i don't want to get
into that right now
what i'm getting into dave chappelle is
cute he's very smart his comedy aptitude
is smart
and listen man when you do a special
you're looking for them to talk about
that special
and how do you get people to talk about
a special
to talk about stuff that's on the other
side that nobody else will touch
now he's been doing it on a couple
specials you know he's been hitting him
with the [__] lgbtq jokes
which means obviously it's a big hang in
his [__] fence
like if i ever was to do stand-up comedy
i would talk about what's going on now
with the schools what they want to teach
you know what affects me directly what's
gonna [__] affect me yeah i'll tell
you some stories [__] that's gone on the
last year [__] that's been funny to me
whatever blah blah blah but no
this whole thing stand up is we're a
conduit
and in that conduit
if it goes if this is the conduit when
it comes in here it's rough when it
comes out it's like a trumpet we're just
blowing it out in a different way with a
little bit of [__] humor
that's all we're doing
now
netflix got a lot of complaints netflix
you know they're demanding that they
take the special down
number one
my heart goes out to the lgbt community
i understand but we're going around
about this all wrong okay
not we i'm not part of the lgbt
community i'm just saying that
they're going about this all wrong there
was a way to go around this you know the
employees
listen
the world has changed
you know uh employees getting suspended
employees getting
whatever
i don't agree with that that was just
wrong i'm both parties that was wrong on
both parties but we're talking about
money here
you're not going to get in front of
money with your feelings nobody
in today's world right now with the
greed that's going on there was supposed
to be a strike today
there was supposed to be a strike over
the weekend uh
the international theaters electricians
caterers grips
all this [__] you know
it was scary that would be a [__]
scary strike because all the networks
wouldn't have been able to work except
hbo
cinemax showtime i forget what the list
was that would have been [__] scary
for us right now you know especially
after the 18-month lockdown you know the
rent whatever it would have been [__]
scary for people mandates now with this
[__]
so
they settled it i just when i woke up
sunday morning i saw that they they
settled at the last [__] minute i
don't even know how this transpired into
this but
what i was trying to say is you know we
work things out
we have to work things out number one
i'm tipping my hat
and i know i'm gonna anger a lot of
people when i say this i'm tipping my
hat to the president of [__] netflix
i'm tipping my hat that's what you're
supposed to do
you're supposed to stand by
your product you're supposed to stand by
your decision
i'm sure dave said some stuff about
murdering the transvestite or
beating up the transgender or the
lesbian listen
what about when i said i did coke with
my cat
did you really [__] go home and think
that i did coke with my cat
sometimes an over exaggeration is what
makes the joke
funny do you understand me
the over exaggeration of it makes the
joke funny i never did a line of
i never did cope with that [__] cat
i had a 10 minute bit i wrote an
imaginary
story an imaginary of me doing cocaine
with my cat
people would laugh
people love the [__] bit
nobody ever complained to me it was a
[__] joke
that's part comedy has so many different
aspects to it you make fun of it you
exaggerate it you [__] you know
so
that's what this is all about
now
i'm sure dave being dave
and the mind of the comic listen the
mind of the comic
i'm going to tell you what happens with
a comic for you to be a successful comic
and i have a lot of comics on my patreon
now ty sal a lot of young comics i'm
going to tell you something
and this goes for musicians also okay
any great musician
anybody he broke through anybody who
broke through on a comedy level
anybody breaks through on the arts they
broke through because they went against
the mold
they went against the status quo they
went against what they were told
you're not going to make moves by going
up there and giving them what the [__]
they want
years ago i heard a great story and i
patented myself and i'm happy
i'm happy i heard this story when i was
in the comedy two years
or three years in denver kevin
fitzgerald dear friend of mine
i've gone back to this story ten times
this week talking to people was doing a
spot at the comedy works
he was opening up not opening up you
know if you know anything about the
comedy works
it's a couple different comics and then
the headliner goes up that's why it's a
hard club to work because you have to
follow eight headliners that's why a lot
of people are like [__] i'm not working
the comedy works you have to follow she
takes the comics that are home the
headline is that a home from tuesday to
thursday and puts them up there and you
have to follow him so anyway
he was one of the many comics he just
happened to be going up before bill
hicks he brought up bill hicks for the
first show
great show nobody complained there was a
second show
bill hicks's road uh
manager went up to him and said listen
kevin
uh
mr hicks does a similar marijuana joke
this is your brain on drugs this is your
brain on mountain
he goes you know it would be great if
you didn't do that joke
kevin fitzgerald looked him in the eye
and said i won't do it and went on stage
and did it
when he got off stage
the guy tried to muscle him and when
bill hicks got off stage he hired him as
an opener
and kevin fitzgerald ended up going up
on the road with bill hicks what a
[__] honor that is
i wouldn't shut up about it when p if i
got to open up for bill hicks and got to
be schooled by bill hicks i just walk
around my dick out like [__] uh like
uh my man brad pitt after legends of the
fall
forget about it just take your dick out
who gives a [__]
but if if bill hicks hired you
after he told you not to do something
what does that mean
that is
what makes a comic tick
if you tell me before i go on stage
not to say that joke i'm gonna say it
how many people watch fresh out of
compton you watch fresh out of compton
when they went to detroit what the
[__] guy tell them don't do any
police don't do [__] the police
what did they do
they went up there and did [__] the
police that's what we do
that's what makes us different that's
what makes you
cut through that's what when people hear
things like that they go okay that's my
[__] guy
he didn't [__] adhere to what they
told him he didn't he didn't give a [__]
you know and i don't know if you guys
remember this
why did dave chappelle walk away from
the 50 million dollar deal from comedy
central did you ever think of that
because
when you're in the tv business
first off dave chappelle's been doing
this since he was [__] 13 years old
in the city
okay so it's like me i've been doing
this since i was [__]
25. if tomorrow
cbs called me and said we want you to do
a show about
bookies
okay
and you're playing one of the bookies
and after two weeks ah no
after the first season the show is a
success
what's a success it's done great numbers
people like it it's a 8 o'clock show
whatever
what if they come to me after three
years
and say and they go oh we got new show
runners we got new people working at the
network
and what if you
let's say you're 35 years old i'm just
asking you a general question to think
about this on a monday [__] morning
what if you
were
if somebody came to you and you had a
successful hit
and some kid from cbs came to you that
just graduated syracuse
with no television experience just what
they taught him in college maybe a year
and he got promoted to be the liaison
between cbs and you
and he's coming to you saying to you
yeah
this is what needs to be done on this
show you need to do this you need to do
that you need to do this eventually one
day you're going to go time out no
disrespect to you
you just graduated college you don't
even know what the [__] we're doing here
i've been on a [__] street corner
popping jokes on in clubs since i was 13
years old
i've gotten through [__] 18 abc deals
dave chappelle
paid his [__] dues
okay they tried to put him on tv like 20
[__] times with their ideas and they
couldn't get them on tv with their ideas
so finally dave chappelle and neil
brennan created the [__] dave
chappelle show and what happened with
his own brand because they wanted to do
what they wanted to do with dave they
was on tv for years i don't know if you
guys know that dave was on a tv show
with that [__] dude i forget what his
name is now they were trying to do
things with dave i started in comedy in
91 when i came to new york in 93
dave was the golden [__] goose
already i still remember going to boston
comedy club
and seeing him felicia
nick tuturo j moore and going wow
yeah he was in that movie robin hood men
in tights [__] great movie you're not
gonna he [__] walked away from 50
million dollars because you're not gonna
tell me how to do my [__] job and
guess what guys i feel the exact same
way
nobody's ever gonna come and i've had a
thousand arguments over this one of the
reasons why i've taken a breather from
comedy like that i did because i'm
coming back
but i'm doing it my way
not the way the agents wanted to not the
way the promoters wanted to not the way
to [__] comedy club because they
don't [__] know
we're the ones that are busting our
[__] ass so yes
i'm very [__] happy they didn't take
that [__] special down [__]
you
[__] you
and i go back to andrew dice clay
i go back to 1990 91 92 93 with andrew
dice clay and the [__] he went through
let me tell you something
do you think people went to [__] hbo
and told him to take down the hickey
dickery doc [__] special
do you think they went to like hbo and
told him to take down the [__] live
from long island with joey badafuco and
the [__]
no no because people weren't [__]
concerned we're getting too woke we're
getting a little bit too woke again my
apologies to the lgbtq community
but you should handle this a little
differently
get the people that run glad or i don't
know what the name of the organization
schedule a meeting with netflix
don't go in there demanding to take the
special off
just
explain to them what you've been trying
to do online explaining that
tell dave what
you think
his actions were and how they affected
the lgbtq community community
sit them down explain that to netflix
like the
whatever the thing that organization
explained it to tom segura don't go
online and call them out and all this
[__]
schedule a meeting with netflix sit them
down
and explain your beef to your beef to
them
what is going on how this does affect
our community
i think for me
i think he's giving you light like they
say no publicity is bad publicity
you know i think that if you're
on the road to a gender change this is
not gonna [__] you know
so i get it i get the
that in your world the remarks were a
little violent and whatnot and people
gonna start beat no they're not no
they're not
listen i'm a wild man and like i said
i've i've had experience
with transgender people people who have
gone the operation
and i treat them the same do i make
jokes
yeah you have to make jokes so on the
other side of this coin i hate saying
this
lgbtq you got to toughen up a little bit
you got to [__] toughen up a little
bit it's 2021
you're pioneers what do you think
happens to pioneers they get hit in the
head with [__] rocks until they prove
that point until they sell their belief
until they tell you
why they're doing what they're doing you
got to toughen up a little bit what do
you think the gay guys in the 60s and
70s were [__] demanding for you to
take [__] down these were the [__] uh
young gay guys that were getting beat up
in the six think about being gay in the
50s 60s and 70s and you're offended over
a [__] comedian's [__] words on a
special you need to toughen up too
you need to toughen up too i know you
made the commitment to change and to be
stronger and whatever well let's do it
you need to toughen up the [__] too
if you're gonna listen how do you think
you're perceived
right now how do you think you're
perceived when you walk into a a job and
you're in the transition and you know
you you're taking you know how are you
perceived did you ever think about that
so yes this is an education for
everybody
but the lgbtq community needs to educate
people and explain to us what's going on
why it's hurtful
don't just
take the special down no
no
no we're not [__] the nfl no
we're not [__] uh al davis that we're
just gonna sell somebody up to the
[__] sharks no
let's do this let's try this let's speak
to some of the african-american people
that he's come in contact with gruden
before we let them go see if they're
[__] angry about they've been getting
coached by him for the last since 2012.
without any knowledge of these [__]
emails does it make a difference
does it [__] make a difference so we
have to toughen up a little bit in this
[__] country we have a lot of issues
right now going on that we have to
[__] worry about mental health they
just a lot they just told cops in new
york that if you see somebody shooting
heroin on the street it's fine they're
don't don't [__] [__] with them
they're trying to
vaccinate your [__] kid they're
trying to make mandates for you to get
on planes for that you they're trying to
take away your [__] liberties
and you're worried about an
african-american comedian making jokes
that's what you're [__] worried about
right now lgbt community they are going
for our [__] heads they are going for
our [__] heads
so i understand you being woke i get it
i understand we all have to do a little
bit awakening or as much as we could do
i've even woken up a little bit i'm not
listen that doesn't mean i'm not gonna
crack [__] jokes okay i'm gonna crack
[__] jokes but now i also have a
knowledge of who i'm hurting with these
jokes that's the most important thing
but listen if a joke hurts you
take a [__] you know
what the [__] is wrong with you what the
[__] is wrong with us have we gotten
this [__] soft in our [__] daily
lives that everything [__] affects us
people are dying right now from stupid
[__]
people are [__] losing their job
school teachers cops you know it's a
whole new [__] world out there but
you want to create another [__]
problem because
a comedian
said some [__]
stupid [__] about you i don't i don't
understand society anymore and i'm
trying to be woke i'm you know i have a
little girl i have a family i have
friends that have sons and daughters
that are trying to you know uh change
genders his he they it's too [__]
much
it's too [__] much altogether
you know you got us on this [__] path
of you know that we can't do nothing
wrong and if we did something 20 years
ago we should be punished tomorrow no
and you guys know anything about me i
didn't allow it [__] 18 months ago
and i'm not gonna [__] allow it i'm
not gonna allow and i'm not gonna
determine one thing i did come up with a
conclusion when i watched that special
i'm gonna be honest with you guys i'm
gonna be as honest as i can with you
because i've always been honest with you
guys
one of the reasons i have
stayed clear of stand up
is because i have a lot of things going
on in my
life and i don't need somebody
to make a tape of me
and say i was saying wrong [__]
and they shut me down over stupid stuff
over
i was on a roll on stage i'm on a
[__] roll i'm just going
and all of a sudden i drop something a
[__] joke a gay joke
a [__] an african-american joke a
chinese joke
and my life is gonna be over because of
today's society and the [__] wokeness
that's not gonna that's not gonna work
but i've been thinking about it and ever
since i watched a chappelle special
i go no
this cannot this cannot go on chappelle
special woke me up
chappelle special woke me up a lot and
the the gruden thing woke me up a lot i
had been the [__] little bear cave
for the last [__] year that really
woke me up and guess what
now it's giving me a [__] now i want
to do stand up
now i want to do some assets i called
dino last week and i go dino dino
offered me a couple dates and i go dina
listen
again i can't cover an hour and i'm not
going to do that to anybody i'm not
going to charge you 20 bucks and go
listen if i have 15 minutes i wouldn't
mind because i got somewhere to go and
we could improvise but now
because of what i've seen chappelle do
i'm gonna tell you what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna go back out there just in jersey
for now
for the first six months just to get my
listen guys it takes a long time
to come up with an hour of material no
matter how much you [__] right you
got to go out there and test it and test
it and re-fucking test it
so it takes time i am the type of guy
that i refuse
to put myself out there in a theater if
i'm not at least
30 minutes in of great [__] material
but because of the chappelle thing he
inspired me i was looking
for something to inspire me and i found
it
i found it you're not going to ever
you know damon wayne's gave the best
[__] response to it
he said they made comedian slaves
they wanted to make us [__] slaves to
their and i'm not doing it and i'm happy
he said those words i'm happy dave did
what he did and i'm happy i'm gonna do
what i'm gonna [__] do
i'm gonna go up there little by little
take my time
but i'm not gonna miss my words because
i'm gonna hurt somebody's feelings
that's not what a stand-up is supposed
to do the stand-ups that aren't
successful that's why they're not
successful because they pander to the
audience and they don't want to [__]
they don't want to tippy-toe around
anybody's [__] feelings
i don't give a [__] i really don't
you know what when i go out and i get
offended by something i get offended by
two or three things but guess what
you'll never hear me talk about them
because what difference does it make
what do you want me to do send them an
email that they offended me with a joke
or a commercial you offend me when you
put tampon commercials on
what kind of [__] half a [__] would i
[__] be if i did that so
no i just avoid those situations so like
if something gives you anxiety
that's one thing i've learned from
better help
and something gives you anxiety avoid
it's called the [__] trigger
right or wrong so if you think you're
gonna get [__] sad about dave
chappelle special don't watch it
don't watch it what 10 million [__]
people have watched it
and they've enjoyed it i mean you know
so my heart goes out to the lgbt
community i hope you didn't take any of
my comments in the wrong way
i'm just trying to explain to everybody
how we could avoid all this and what you
should worry about and what you should
not worry about i spoke about
before how i'm not the most well-read
guy i'm a street guy i'm a street guy
i'm a high school
[__] dropout for me to talk about the
social issues of the world means i have
to sit down and read for [__] 10
[__] years but that time i'll be dead
and [__] buried anyway so i don't
have time for that i talk about life
i talk about how to make your life
better i talk about
you know our freedoms how to [__] you
know who gives a [__] what they think
it's what you think that's [__]
important if you don't like what they
think just turn them the [__] off that's
it it's that [__] simple that's the
school i've been from all my [__]
life i worry about what's in front of me
i'm like a i'm not a political guy but
i'm like a democratic
mind guy i don't really think about
what's going on out there it's got
nothing to do with me it's got nothing
to do with me it's what's in front of me
i've never had it as good as people that
they could think about you know the
pygmies and
in [__] indonesia i you know i love
to think about pygmies and i love to
save the [__] children and all this
[__] but who has the [__] time
we have time to talk about what we know
what's in our realm and what's in our
world for me it's movies
reefer i've never realized how worthless
i am
since i moved here
like i was ever since i stopped doing
comment i'm like i need a job what can i
do
nothing
nothing this is all i could do is crack
stupid [__] jokes
and talk and [__] do a podcast and
maybe shoot a couple videos from time to
time that's all i could do and i'm very
happy for that that's why i was [__]
kidding myself if i thought i was gonna
do anything else i'm happy i watched
that dave chappelle special and i'm
happy it gave me some [__] uh
initiative to at least go on stage from
time to time
i love you [__] with all my
heart man uh
i'm a lot better i'm feeling a lot
better i'm a lot happier uh like i said
it's getting we're getting f we're
moving jack
i mean
mike was saying it was 91 [__]
degrees
come friday and now it's 60 [__] two
life is moving it was october 1st
everybody was happy that many saints
were out and now it's october [__]
17th 18th whatever the [__] it is
time is moving brother and if you don't
get on this [__] boat you're going to
be left out there i love you
[__] with all my heart
laughing gas is back
and what'd you think of the new batch
it's tremendous i like that new batch
i like that new batch i'm trying to try
to mix it up a lot but it's so weird how
uh
i got so far i'm loving this guys listen
the reason i got high in the morning
was because of how high i got in the
mornings as a pot aficionado right the
reason why you get high in the morning
is to have it hit you like a left hook
so you don't have to [__] think about
what you're about to do or whatever
let me tell you something i don't even i
don't even want to smoke pot in the
daytime no more i don't want to smoke
pot in the daytime no more because the
two-hour window at night when i smoke
i get so high and i have such a [__]
good time
i can't even tell you how much of a
great time i have when i get high at
night i do so many [__] things in
that two-hour window and when i go
upstairs and my head hits the pillow
zoom i finally got over
to not eating [__] at night because that
was killing me i put out a few pounds
but i took him right to back [__] off
because i started eating apples and
bananas at night but [__]
for a few weeks there i was going deep
the tapering is going great i maybe have
another [__] month of it
and i'm done and i feel great guys i
really [__] do thank you
for all the support and all the well
wishes and
for support and we've had some great
podcasts the last couple weeks
it is what it is
and i'm happy you're enjoying them have
a great week have a great [__] monday
i'll see you [__] wednesday tip
top magoo i think we're gonna bring some
[__] conspiracies on the show i love
you [__] see you wednesday
morning and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors jack all right
you bad [__] i want to thank
you i had a good time with you guys
today it's monday it's a great way to
start the week but before we go anywhere
i want to talk to you about better help
online therapy listen going to therapy
is routine maintenance for your mental
and emotional wellness to prevent bigger
issues down the road i didn't know this
i didn't know this i'll tell you what i
am a lot better and you guys have seen
me if you don't believe in better health
or you don't believe in therapy
put on one of the podcasts from november
and look at me how i was talking and
look at me today it's two different
people
dana has really helped me if you want to
go with dana give her a shot but going
to therapy doesn't mean there's
something wrong with you it means you're
investing in yourself to keep your mind
healthy for the future and that's what i
did and i hope you do the same better
help is customized online therapy that
offers video chat phone
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want you want to talk on the
phone you talk on the phone you want to
see what she looks like she's right
there for you it's much more affordable
than in person therapy and you can start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours why invest in anything
else
and not your mind come on this podcast
is sponsored by better help
and joint listeners can get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhelp.com
diaz
the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion when it comes to cbd why are
you buying your [__] cbd at a goddamn
gas station cbd line has everything that
you need
from the cream to the kinesiology tape
to the bat balls to broad spectrum
capsules 30 to 1
milligram i mean listen
cbd line has been there for me for years
i'm trying to turn them on t you guys
know i don't bring nothing to the table
that doesn't work and isn't 100 [__]
tremendous
cbd lion is 100 [__] percent
tremendous do me a favor go to
cdbdline.com right now and read
learn the third party lab results
learn about cbd and cbn you're going to
be happy you got a bum knee take care of
it the winter's coming now is the time
to do all that stuff go to cbdline.com
right now
order the kinesiology tape the cbd
gummies anything that they have and i'm
going to give you 20 off your order when
you press in joey on the way out cbd
lion the best the joint is also brought
to you by
draftkings listen
nfl football you guys are hungry for a
big win this week of course you are and
it starts tonight with the titans
against the buffalo bills at tennessee
getting [__] five points draftking
sportsbook has you covered tonight and
the rest of the week that means thursday
that means tuesday for baseball that
means wednesday and thursday for college
football but this week we're going to
focus on nfl bet five dollars on any nfl
team to win their game and if they do
you win two hundred dollars and free
bets
you want me to repeat that five dollars
and you win 203 bets winner winner
[__] chicken dinner and that's
not all draftkings has a social network
if you're on there look me up
and we'll [__] chit chat on there
we'll talk about games
and whatnot who's playing who's not
playing who's winning who's got [__]
locks and if sportsbook isn't available
in your state yet no worries draftkings
won't leave you with your dick in your
hand everyone can play for huge cash
prizes all season long with draftkings
daily fantasy sports contest
draftkings has given all new customers a
free shot at millions of dollars in
total prizes with their first deposit so
what the [__] are you waiting for
download the draftking sportsbook app
today
use promo code joey j-o-e-y
betches five owls on any nfl team to win
their game and win 200
and free bets
where you gonna get that action from
nowhere and if they win you win use
promo code joey this week at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nfl and here's the stuff
the lawyers make me say you got to be 21
or older new jersey indiana pennsylvania
only
new customers only
minimum five hour deposit and five
dollar wage are required
one more thing
one per customer
don't be cute restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com sportbook for details now
if you got a gaming problem
call 1-800 gambler
if you don't have a problem and your
head is in the right place it's time to
win some [__] money head to
draftkings.com
and code joey and let's make this
[__] happen and don't forget to
friend me i want to thank draftkings i
want to thank
better help online therapy and i want to
thank cbd lion for having my back but
most importantly i want to thank you
[__] savages for having my
[__] back thank you i love you
and we'll be back wednesday morning tip
top [__] magoo have a great day
i love you [__]
um
hmm
you